mario kann sich ja mal zwischen uns
beiden entscheiden und das wird und das
will ich auch dass er das macht ich
fordere dich heraus
du warst der seinem zettel hat sie
gerade ihre arbeitskollegen zur tour
bette herausgefordert rtl2 weiß ganz
genau in unserer heutigen gesellschaft
sind andere dinge wichtig als sie es
noch zu den zeiten unserer eltern waren
damals noch gezählt einen guten job hat
die gute ausbildung hat eine familie
gegründet hat die sich liebt und
zusammenhält heutzutage zählt nur noch
eins ist der eigene hintern perfekt
genau dem entsprechen sind wir alle froh
das hilft mir ein bestimmt sehr
hochwertiges und keinesfalls abstoßendes
video mit dem namen die suche nach dem
perfekten xxl hintern gemacht hat da
wären wir heute reinschauen und wir
werden versuchen zu verstehen wie die
heutigen teenager ticken die nur noch an
eines denken ja schon ganz christoph
anfang wollte ich finde hilft mir sollte
mal die bio updaten da steht immer noch
drin was natürlich vollkommen falsch ist
die ratgeberserie zeigt geschichten von
jungen menschen die mit finanziellen
problemen liebeskummer stress in der
schule oder mit eltern zu kämpfen haben
das natürlich kompletter unsinn er sie
als wir wissen es auch das einzige
problem was teenager heutzutage haben
ist dass sie nicht den perfekten xxl
hintern haben half aber vielleicht sehen
sie an dem video hier wie man ihn
bekommt
die
[Musik]
die clubs stellen
ok wieder für mich persönlich ein leicht
schmerzhafter anfang hier dass es wieder
in köln gedreht und alle diese szene die
am anfang gesehen habt sie sind dann
wirklich so ein zwei kilometer höchstens
von dem ort entfernt wo ich dass sie
gerade auf nehme ich weiß nicht warum
aber ich fühle mich jetzt gerade
irgendwie ein bisschen beobachtet sehr
gut wieder sehr hochwertige einstieg in
diese folge von rtl 2
also leute ihr habt genau fünf sekunden
um die komplette handlung dieses videos
zu erklären und es macht wieder
überhaupt keinen sinn sie arbeitet
scheinbar in diesem supermarkt und wer
der noch halbwegs bei sinnen ist in
seinem leben geht zu seinem eigenen
chefin und erzählt dem chef übrigens ich
habe mich in den duden verliebt ich weiß
dass hat keinerlei relevanz für mein
arbeitsverhältnis in diesem laden und
wahrscheinlich interessiert sich auch
nicht und ist ganz andere themen weil du
fast 30 jahre älter ist als ich ich
wollte noch mal sagen der mario geile
sau gemacht muss auf jeden fall
versuchen werden auf jeden fall nicht
unbedingt die klügste entscheidung also
ich muss sagen dafür dass es eine
ratgeberserie sein soll ist es relativ
schwacher live und weiß leute wenn ihr
irgendwo eine ausbildung macht oder
irgendwo schon arbeitet vergeht nicht zu
eurem chefin und sagt dem in wenig
verliebt zeit weil er wird das heißt wir
nicht sagen hey klar ich unterstütze ich
dabei sondern wir sagen geben sagt
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
ja ja ja ja natürlich ja klar es ist ein
ganz klassischer tag im rewe center in
köln lindenthal im vordergrund auf der
verkaufsfläche wo auch die kunden
rumlaufen ist natürlich alles ganz
normal
selbstverständlich wird auch im
hintergrund im büro einfach mal der
arsch von irgend einer fremden frau
vermessen der das video 6 30 sekunden
alt aber das war es eigentlich wieder
komplett eigentlich kann ich jetzt schon
wieder aufhören das ist alles wird das
video gesagt
es muss jetzt etwas gesehen hat der weiß
mit diesem tür und tor ist heute ganz
gut ist dass überhaupt ein mensch
es wird sowieso eine außerirdische
lebensform diese versucht mensch zu sein
naja missverständnis diesen
gesichtsausdruck toten die mir würde ich
wieder mal beim vermessen von weiblichen
hinterteilen erwischt werde gerade für
den für den kittel für die
arbeitskleidung ja ja mir geht es
ungefähr so wie diesen typen hier auf
der rechten seite die einzige frage die
sich uns beiden jetzt an der stelle
gestellt ist wo sind wir hier schon
wieder gelandet einer maß genommen
vor ihm sieht gut aus aber weiter zurück
das ist doch keine komfortablen position
sie hängt so an dieser tür ja das ist
eine sehr bequeme position für mich ich
will einfach macht ihr euer ding dinge
und freut sie sich auch das muss jetzt
so richtig zufrieden gesichtsausdrücke
ja natürlich ich mein leben vollkommen
auf der hand mal ganz davon abgesehen
dass das natürlich der wichtigste wert
in unserer heutigen gesellschaft ist ist
es auch sehr hilfreich ein möglichst
großes hinterteil zu haben das macht
natürlich vor allem die arbeit im
supermarkt um einiges leichter denn je
voluminöser die eigene hüfte ist desto
schlechter kommt man durch die regale
also perfekt für die optimale arbeit
haben sie doch nicht mehr alle die hat
wohl vergessen wir hier der chef ist sie
da ist total nett und ich habe auch noch
nie so einen geilen arsch gesehen
bewundernswerte logik auf jeden fall
scheinbar ist alles gut und
gerechtfertigt und eingebracht so lange
man das nur machen wenn man chef ist ja
gut stimmt zwar ich hab ne umgestürzt
als sie gerade in der kasse war um zu
bezahlen aber ich bin ja auch chefin im
laden denkt mal nach nicht
ach du scheiße das ist auch noch der
tiefe den sie verliebt ist ah ja das
war's dann gleich zweimal komplett
legende d gabe müssen für jede szene gar
nicht mehr so neuen counter einführen
die einfach mist wie oft es das komplett
war pro gezeigt dass zähne ich würde
sagen hier war es dass auf jeden fall
schon zweimal komplett
ich möchte bitte dass michelle die sina
jetzt ein bisschen ein weißes und ihr
jetzt mal so alles zeigt und sie nach
wenn irgendwas noch ist wenn noch fragen
sind oder so bin ich irgendwas für dich
tun kann wenn ihr mal da er verhält sich
wirklich nicht menschlich so rede ich
mit max also mein bruder oder mit
unserem kumpels wenn wir so wie scheiße
labern genau
ja genau ja ja das recht ich bin immer
für dich da
das war das beste bewerbungsgespräch was
ich je hatte
ich glaube hier zur arbeit mit mir spaß
machen also nicht das arbeiten die
aussage verstehe ich nicht ganz ich
glaube hier zu arbeiten wird mir spaß
machen aber nicht das arbeiten erst
einmal die kraft an deinem handy das ist
während der arbeitszeit verboten es sei
denn du hast mir gar nichts zu sagen
wenn ich meinem handy sein weil das was
soll der scheiß montiert nicht mal
arbeitskleidung an
was ist das für ein laden warum um alles
in der welt hast du jetzt nicht schon
wieder das haben wir jetzt eben gerade
wirklich groß und breit diskutiert das
thema nein nein haben wir nicht und wir
sind auch noch zu keinerlei vernünftigen
lösung und erklärung dafür gekommen dass
du das gemacht hast
ja ich glaub mir das ist das ist ein
straftatbestand konnte natürlich
sexuelle belästigung arbeitsplatz kommt
jetzt mal halblang
es ist ziemlich genau das was er gesagt
hat unter dem video kommentiert jemand
mit namen sophie love ist jemandem
aufgefallen dass überhaupt keine käufer
hellen hüllen sind ja das ist wirklich
so ein klassisches phänomen dass diese
hilfen erfolgen scheinbar irgendwelchen
seltsam parallel und die weisen
entstehen wo anscheinend supermärkte
bestehen können ohne dass leute in den
supermärkten irgendwas kaufen macht den
job zu bekommen
er ist was was hat sie gesagt dass man
das zensieren muss der mario der marius
schon immer gesagt tatsächlich niemals
auf mitarbeiter einlassen sollte lang
gerade auf dich ja was ihr auch bemerken
sie hat noch irgendwie nicht so ganz den
unterschied zwischen ch und sch
verstanden wissen was meine leute der
unterschied zwischen kirche und kirche
ja in das eine geht man rein in das
andere beißt man rein bei ihr ist alles
kirche gemütlich ganz eindeutig wir
haben es hier mit einem klaren
konkurrenzkampf zu tun zwischen den
beiden frauen aber dieser
konkurrenzkampfes gar nicht selbst
gemacht sondern der es initiiert wurden
durch marius verhalten
sorry also tut mir leid dass ich dich
unterbrechen muss hier geschätzte hilfen
experte aber ich muss noch mal sagen was
zur hölle ist das für eine arbeit die
auf der rechten seite also ganz normal
schwarze schuhe dunkle jeans halt
irgendwie zumindest mal ein oberteil was
zu dem laden gehört man erkennen kann ob
die arbeitet da die linke leggins zehn
zentimeter absätze der das ist ihr
bewerbungsfoto heft das ist jedem
bewerbungsfoto samara mario sticht das
problem stehe ich hätte gerne mal dass
du und
das hier beide mehr respekt vor meiner
person habt wie soll das gehen wie soll
man mehr respekt vor seiner person haben
noch mehr als jetzt schon
also ich habe mega viel respekt vor ihm
es ist ein irrenhaus
ich habe eine theorie leute und zwar der
supermarkt ist kurz davor pleite zu
gehen und der supermarktleiter dieser
typ mit der brille ist einfach menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend und im
zuge dessen ist dann irgendwo einen
wahren zustand abgerutscht und denkt
jetzt das ist ein wichtiges
einstellungskriterium ist wie groß das
hinterteil einer bewerberin oder auch
eines männlichen bewerber ist okay tag 2
sie hat immer noch keine arbeitskleidung
an kleine rohde fehlt aber noch eine
kleinigkeit oder ich weiß es nicht
er ist tatsächlich selbst drauf gekommen
ok hatte bei 194 stunden dauert der
marsch der frist mir echt total aus der
hand der glaub mir wirklich einfach
alles mein silikon inter macht sich
bezahlt
die einzige person die das sagen kann es
schön david alter die sitze einfach
diese geste und macht keine allofs l
hieß dann hat er wohl auch wenn er
diesen ländern was steuert das zu dem
bild bei dass sie einfach gemüse in der
hand hat hättest du das gemüse und in
die kiste liegen können selbst
sicherlich nicht das gemüse muss mit
drauf wir mussten aber unterbrechen
welche kunden das ist meine privatsphäre
was interessiert euch darüber ab wer
privat zahlen erst hast du dich
rausschmeißen okay also schonmal kann ja
niemand was mal dass ihre privatsphäre
ist scheinbar ist es teil ihrer
privatsphäre in hohen schuhen leggins
und bh und einer metzger schürze in
einem supermarkt zu setzen und mit auch
noch ein fucking safestick alter wo sie
den ausgegraben das war 2014 mal in das
nennt sich dann also privatsphäre
[Musik]
naja der kopierten defekt verständlich
dann das erklärt natürlich alles daran
weil wir alle wissen wenn der kopierer
defekt hat ist es natürlich erst mal die
erste reaktion die die beste maßnahme
zumindest im ersten schritt das man
erstmal einen ausgewachsenen menschen
nimmt und diesen ausgewachsen menschen
auf den kopierer draufsetzt außerdem hat
bei dieser sina auch dies trieb mit
korrekt der arbeitsteilung nicht lange
gehalten
sie hat die metzger schürze vom zweiten
arbeitstag mit der sie natürlich auch
selbst gemacht hat jetzt einfach
eingetauscht gegen wie so ein
bauchtänzer outfit und eine jacke
man kann sich ja mal zwischen uns beiden
entscheiden und das wird und das will
ich auch dass er das macht ich fordere
dich heraus zu was der seinem zu
ermitteln was ist das denn für eine
scheiße schon wieder
das wirklich gesagt hat sie gerade ihre
arbeitskollege zu einem tourstädte
herausgefordert das war es auf jeden
fall mal komplett ganz ehrlich leute ich
glaube so könnte so ein albtraum von mir
aus sehen dass ich in so einer welt auf
wache wo es einfach nur noch darum geht
wer besser turnen kann und wer den
größeren hintern hat okay es hätte auch
was positives aber größtenteils weise
negativ alle menschen um die kompletten
verstand verloren und es geht nur noch
um dieses eine thema so wirkt diese
folge auf mich aber so die komplette
menschheit ist einfach wahnsinnig
geworden ja leute wie ich glaube wir
haben alle keine fragen mehr ich wünsche
euch gute erholung von diesem video
falls ihr noch eine weitere dosis
braucht gibt's hier drüben für euch
vorgeschlagen das video
ich weiß nicht vielleicht von tieren in
den kommentaren erklären wie sich dieser
supermarkt finanziert wenn da kein
einziger kunde eingeht
ich wäre sehr dankbar für eure hilfe
leute bis zum nächsten mal